I know when to welcome home to this
video playing passwords okay if I'm not
deciding it what to do it let's go with
concrete and steel 93 this is actually
rare they tend to play 93 a lot doesn't
doesn't take okay
it's an interesting strategy when the
Bishop's not so bad on f5 so what will
go night f1 very likely you have to
untangle somehow
yeah I wanted to play night something
like night c4 anyway is that bad but
seem let's see I mean b3 I even have
night b2 as weird as it looks and then
jump to d3
isn't that a move okay I can take okay
doesn't get too much so let's do this it
looks funny but 93 as a it's a fork not
a [ __ ] that immediately wins something
but the bishop way I have you want okay
it's not so easy actually
if he goes rookie - I can take b3 that's
interesting and rookie twist to move
that I guess he would like to play the
group d1 looks a little bit pointless
there might even win win material oh
that is an interesting choice but I can
take the rock right why not
I have 592 I am that cannot be enough
what's going on there so is there a
threat Bishop h6f Bishop f8 so I don't
think so
let's take me through okay stay away
tune
[Music]
you know I mean I don't mind if he takes
this back latex takes with this okay
trying to invade now it's just an
exchange basically don't see any any
particular compensation queen queen G
for maybe a queen to f3 he wants to go
Queen to f3 anyway to stop that okay I
have to do this move anyway so let's
play it because queen chief why I need
to stop
so Queen f3 mmm
my queen on a eight looks a little bit
does it look so great Queen f3 no it
doesn't do it
so let's let's just want the Queen
nearer the important parts of the pot
Queenie six Queenie for Miriam
who cares own night Eve or let's
centralize
I think I'm trading one one piece now
it's they don't see how we can avoid
that okay Queenie to
so what's going on there night III is
not a threat because of cause of g5
mmm g6 96 and then it's really very easy
to win against the bishop in this
position because he cannot care to check
my pawns and I'm just starting to to
grab things in the long run note that
his he will run out of moves him King
has no way forward or King h5 kickin go
here
no h5 is good but it's not necessary
right he cannot go yeah but if I can you
can do it okay so let's see how do we
get it super swung in place maybe I
don't
I mean this will win but I thought I
could could do something a little bit
more clever but didn't find anything
okay he resigned yeah I will start to
pick up points now so what do we have
it was a fairly normal opening here
they usually trade or play night
everyone so it's a little bit odd to
children to retreat but okay it's still
equal equally yeah I wanted to get some
something going gain a bit of space and
yeah he needs to be more precise
probably night is three is still equal
but here I'm just bad I am and it's a
little bit difficult now to make a movie
play tonight age four which was bad but
um yeah look here here thought if I'm
take Quinn takes I thought this might be
an option maybe it's not nice to be one
at the end tab and then I have no other
option to give it back okay I mean I can
just take and play the position of
course like this and I've gotten the
bishop and I've got some some things to
play against on the Queen side
yeah after night aged form just
basically just the exchange maybe I can
play more forcefully I think it was it
was okay
now I'm going to trade more pieces 95
Yahoo came but it's totally okay to
trade this okay
yeah thanks for watching